this is CNN Texas authorities have begun
arresting migrants at a public park near
the US Mexico border official says Texas
authorities arrested migrants at Shelby
Park in Eagle Pass Texas late Wednesday
evening and charged them with criminal
trespassing marking the first arrests of
migrants since the state took control of
the area at the US Mexico border last
week and officials said the arrests were
announced by Lieutenant Chris Al Oliver
alerz how you pronoun Al Al at the Texas
Department of Public uh of Public Safety
on social media where he also posted
videos on acts we get it we get it
single adult migrant men and women were
taken into State custody while migrant
families and children were transferred
to US border patrol I'm hearing that the
Texas planes and buses that were
shipping migrants to to various cities
have either stopped or slowed around the
same time the state has begun arresting
the illegal immigrants okay my friends
social breakdown the federal government
declares the border the international
borders are their Authority and I
believe that is the case but they are
also obligated under article 4 section 4
of The Constitution to defend States
from Invasion the federal government is
facilitating Invasion not doing their
Duty so Texas says we no longer adhere
to what you are claiming Texas is now
solely enforcing the law on their border
passing a law saying that they have the
authority and jurisdiction on this
international border the federal
government sues them saying no you don't
Texas deploys armed National Guardsmen
to Bar Federal Agents from the border
from the river and we have the makings
of the grain grains of sand are being
added to the to the Heap of secession
wow so does this escalate to the point
where Texas eventually declares
independence it may all of these small
moments when you know I always use this
analogy how many grain of grains of sand
make a Heap what we are watching right
now is Texas asserting its own authority
over an international border Texas
deploying armed soldiers to Bar federal
agents from what the federal agents
claim is their
jurisdiction if the federal government
backs down and gives up this just
shatters confidence in the federal
government if they want to so what does
it mean for other states next you get
New Mexico Arizona other states being
like well the federal government has no
Authority anymore they've given up and
they'll start asserting their own
authority or the federal government
shows up in force with guns and says
stand down and if that happens we have
to ask Will Texas Stand Down or will
Texas say F you know right and where
does that
lead that's really fascinating I feel
like we're Americans it seems like
America as a whole is going back to I
don't want to make it seem like it's
radical but kind of it roots and its
culture of just keeping the government
accountable and if you won't take care
of this nation we will cuz that's kind
of how the founder fathers were I feel
like just Americans as a whole they're
going to start making the founder
fathers proud and that's not saying to
start a revolution or anything or even
no promotion of stand on your rights
yeah they're standing on the rights and
telling the government they've taken too
much power give it back to the stat I
mean this was Abbott's criticism of
immigration for for a long time now that
there are laws in the books that the
federal government could choose to
enforce and they don't in fact they have
let this become a a increasingly
burdensome problem for the states to
deal with and then telling States they
can't do anything to stop it and so I
think in some ways this rise of you know
a state Governor that is willing to do
something is uh inspirational I think
it's more likely that border states
would follow suit and I actually wonder
if it's going to be the the States along
northern border they're going to do
something to right they're seeing a wave
of immigration as well I mean at a
certain point it's a danger to people
yeah there's the not doing well people
will fly to Canada and cross through the
northern B oh wow the other the other
thing too is a lot of what's going on in
terms of um family separation and just
releasing migrant kids and releasing the
people who travel with migrant kids
creating essentially a golden ticket for
adults who bring kids across the border
it it's not a law it was it's a judge
it's a Flores settlement that went
through in 1987 and then has been
consistently challenged and back and
forth where I think it
was 20 it was under the Obama
Administration uh there was this judge G
in um or maybe it's g in California who
said that since because of the Flores
settlement says that you have to release
immigrant children illegal immigrant
children without any do without any real
delay that meant that you also have to
release the adults that came with them
so it created this golden ticket
situation where the um border patrol the
DHS is required to release children
under this agreement and if they're
releasing children they have to release
the adults too and that's actually how
the family separation thing happened
because under Obama it was like okay you
have to release ille illegal immigrant
children so let's separate them so that
we can release the children and detain
the the adults that came with them and
then that was that was changed so I
don't know why everyone's holding to
this
um ruling by a radical judge why is that
what's being upheld it's pretty weird I
think we're about to start seeing a lot
of positive Domino effects from the last
about 12 years we've seen a negativity
of domino effects and nothing I don't
care what someone does with their
sexuality but there has been a downward
spir rle in America after Obama
legalized homosexual marriage at first I
do distinctly remember the lgbtq
community simply only asking for the
right to be married after that they
started asking for representation in
television and it went from television
to kid TV shows and went from kid TV
shows to going to preschools and Etc so
it's a domino effect of just legalizing
the marriage itself or even it wasn't
Obama it was the Supreme Court yeah but
uh it was in the Obama yeah it was
oberfell the decision yeah I look the
domino effect the slippery slope these
things are are are real they happen and
so everything we're seeing now with
Texas on the
border I want to make I want to make
sure it's clear I'm not actually
predicting anything I I I'm saying if x
then Y and what I said several months
ago is if Texas is arguing that the
federal Governor has abandoned them
sooner or later they're going to send
law enforcement to go and do this
themselves well then they did it's not
so much that I'm saying like I have a
vision I see this there's multiple
things that could happen here federal
government go Inn a lawsuit Texas backs
down we have no idea but we can say
these things all move in One Direction
so we're going to see Texas now they
arrests sooner or later we're going to
see the federal government retaliate in
some way you have no authority to detain
these people could it escalate to the
most extreme what if Federal the federal
authorities go to local uh jails and
bring guns and say transfer these people
into our custody Texas says no you're
going to release them into our state and
the federal government says we don't
care what you think release them now
into our custody a lot these things
could happen but they don't have any
jurisdiction over state prisons they
only have Juris Federal AR the argument
is that the state has no jurisdiction
over illegal immigration so the federal
government would be saying you have
illegally
detained people that are under our
jurisdiction could you really see
Biden's DHS being like we're going to
get the guns all they know is lawfare
that's what they do
consistently I don't know perhaps it's
very very simple and the answer is no
the federal government backs down if
that's the case other states are going
to say then the federal government is
impotent and incapable how many times
have they back down truthfully how many
times can I remember like can we
remember in recorded history the federal
government backing down yeah our
government backing down well I remember
like Ruby Ridge M you know I I remember
the federal government refusing to back
down to such a degree they kill a bunch
of kids in a at Waco yeah and Waco as
well yeah so I don't I suppose the issue
here is that we're dealing with state
law enforcement versus Federal but again
1860 right 1861 more precisely
that ideally and hopefully Donald Trump
gets elected he then goes to Tex and
says our forces at your are at your
disposal and then there's no longer
animosity and there's no longer a clash
but right now the Biden Administration
is facilitating an invasion and
facilitating illegal immigration and
human smuggling Texas is trying to do
its best to stop the criminal activity
of the Biden Administration but only in
so far as it affects their state sooner
or later we have to reconcile with this
country that the Biden Administration is
a criminal Enterprise for facilitating
human smuggling and they've been doing
it for years they have been it's like 10
million people they're flying children
on planes they are smuggling such an
extreme degree they're trafficking
children yeah from Venezuela and all
over yeah it's interesting too because
you have the Democrats freaking out when
Trump says that there's going to be a
mass deportation event and there's going
to people are going to be held before
they're deported and then you have Eric
Adams the mayor of New York saying you
know what we're gonna do because there's
all this crime around the the illegal
immigrant shelters we're going to put in
curfews at these shelters and it's like
so you're making a detention camp for
migrants where they can't leave right
that's what you're doing so Eric Adams
is going to do it and one thing that's
interesting too is we see that happening
a lot with Democrat Mayors where they
are forced to use the same tactics that
everyone's did crying what's his name
Johnson in Chicago as well I wonder how
extensive their uh just their motives of
getting to the country is I know they
also dig to go from underground and come
back up I just wonder how organized they
have it now just the illegal IM very
organiz because all they have to do is
show up and they're let in well yeah you
have that too yeah like who needs a
tunnel they're just going to open the
door you see border patrol like putting
T um ladders up to like help people
climb over there's a video of border
patrol opening the gate and letting them
in onto private property too because
they'll say it's too dangerous like we
have to help them because otherwise they
might fall and hurt themselves I want to
see Texas National Guards that arresting
the CBP
guys it'd be interes interesting I would
ra I I mean I think it's more likely
that um the federal agents I would like
to see them defect to the state level I
would like to see them leave their jobs
I mean obviously they work in an
industry you know you know if if your
expertise is working on the border just
go to the agency that's actually
enforcing the law and that's allowing
you I do not understand how there are
men and women in law enforcement in the
state of Texas who are actually on the
ground dealing with this every day and
they have not reached the point where
they're just like we got to start
arresting these fed
feds they they are human traffickers I
don't care if they're wearing a badge
they are human traffickers and they are
armed it's time to start arresting them
for facilitating human trafficking it is
human trafficking directly and the
cartels advertise on Tik Tok and
Facebook and what yeah and there was
just a story that we were looking at the
other day Taylor Hansen did it where it
turns out that Catholic Charities
contracted cops in San Antonio to like
facilitate human smuggling human
traffing watch Taylor Hansen's reporting
on ten media we have the culture War uh
show tomorrow morning on tenet media but
Taylor Hansen has uncovered a lot uh
police officers using public equipment
to facilitate human trafficking I mean
dude it is it is insane I I I I I just
don't understand I really don't we are
watching abject evil this is not like a
cop took a bribe these are police
officers in their vehicles using public
equipment to protect and facilitate
human smuggling operations this is not
mean being cute I human trafficking okay
strong language human smuggling
definitive Le 100% there there was a
story I pulled up from the doj from
several years ago where two guys in the
military go to Went to went to prison
for transporting illegal aliens we now
have the entirety of the Biden
Administration facilitating the whole
DHS and I'm just okay I get it perhaps
Texas brief their guys said guys we got
to do this one very very carefully to
avoid dramatic escalation but here's the
move we're going to make if I was in
Texas Sheriff's Department or National
Guard or whatever i' just be I just walk
up to a CBP guy and be like put your
hands on your back I'm you're I don't
care I'm just you know what man people
people always make excuses for cops
always make excuses they say oh you know
cops can't choose what law to enforce
okay if that was the case all of these
guys would be in jail in Texas the
moment a CBP up look let me let me ask
you you guys something if
uh you're you're in a a cartel gang mhm
and you seen driving around a cartel
vehicle and you're armed do you think
the cop's going to go well he's not
doing anything so I'm going to leave him
alone or do you think they're going to
be like that's a cartel vehicle and that
guy's got a gun we're going to pull him
over and and and investigate this is
cartel activity yeah uh if if you were
part of like let's say Al-Qaeda okay a
big Isis truck with an Isis flag is
driving through Texas and a bunch of
guys with with guns are Mount mounted on
the back do you think the cops are going
to be like I can't really enforce
anything they're at the very least going
to investigate and say probable cause is
is a terrorist organization that gives
us the probable cause right to stop them
turns out you have right to keeping be
arms you have right to free speech we
got something interesting going on here
but terrorist organizations are a line
if local law enforcement at state level
knows that all of the
CBP and federal law enforcement have
been facilitating cartel activity and
human smuggling for what for what reason
do they decide I'm not going to even
stop and question these guys yeah it is
because they're like well he's wearing a
badge yeah if a clown walked up to you
wearing a badge I'd say screw off at a
certain point we need the law to be
enforced they're doing it I can respect
it but I don't see why they're giving a
free pass to the criminals in the B
Administration whove been facilitating
this I agree that's why I think that
it's so bizarre that you won't even have
the uh republicans in Congress bring up
the potential impeachment against my
orcus MTG keeps saying like let's imp
Peach Alejandro morcus he's destroying
our hearings right now yeah they're
holding hearings but they haven't they
haven't gone for it and I don't know why
they could have had him out of office
you know 10 months ago they could have
introduced a year ago yeah it's happened
multiple I think it's happened at least
I can think of maybe four times they
they can't get a vote vote on it I don't
know why I mean it just seems like the
most obvious thing I also don't
understand why in a show of good faith
the Biden Administration wouldn't be
like okay mayorcas you got to step down
because we have angered everyone like
they could rotate want it but they could
fake you out with like oh well we listen
to you we're trying to compromise CU
their thing always is is Republicans
aren't willing to compromise you just
heard this from uh JB priter the other
day he was like he sent that he put that
um complaint to Abbott in the new he
begged Greg Abbott to stop sending
illegal stop saying that because you're
being you're you don't respect humanity
and I can't believe you would do this
and it's cold here so agree to a
bipartisan solution right like they are
always saying Republicans are the ones
who aren't willing to compromise when
for Republicans this is the hard issue
you have to close the border you have
close water and it's interesting you had
um Chuck Schumer saying that there would
be no border deal without money for
Ukraine it's like that that makes abely
no sense it's crazy thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net